COMPLETELY SURROUNDED, ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF UKRAINIANS
MAINTAINING THEIR RESISTANCE,
MELISSA BELL IS "OUTFRONT."
>> Reporter: AN EXPLOSION IN THE
SOUTHERN UKRAINIAN CITY OF
MELITOPOL, BLAMED BY MOSCOW ON
UKRAINIAN RESISTERS.
AND ON SUNDAY, MELITOPOL IS
UKRAINE, CHANTED IN THE HEART OF
A TOWN THAT'S BEEN IN RUSSIAN
HANDS FOR NEARLY THREE MONTHS.
YELLOW RIBBONS WERE DEFIANTLY
DISPLAYED THAN ELSEWHERE IN
SOUTHERN UKRAINE.
FROM CRIMEA TO KHERSON, SYMBOLS
OF SILENT RESISTANCE.
BUT MARIUPOL NOT ONLY RESISTED
FROM THE START.
AFTER THE EARLY CHANCE THAT ITS
PEOPLE WERE SILENCED AND THE
TOWN'S MAYOR WAS KIDNAPPED BY
RUSSIAN FORCES IN EARLY MARCH,
SOME LOCALS TURNED TO ARMED
RESISTANCE.
>> IT WAS VERY DANGEROUS.
>> Reporter: NOW A UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT HOLDS UP
ZAPORIZHZHIA, HOLDS UP, SAYS
MARIUPOL WILL NEVER GET UP.
>> THEY CAN KIDNAP, THEY CAN
KILL, BUT WE CAN'T GIVE SUPPORT
BECAUSE OUR CITIZENS DON'T WANT
TO LEAVE TO RUSSIA.
I KNOW IT.
>> Reporter: MARIUPOL FELL
QUICKLY AND EVEN AS RUSSIAN
FORCES FELL BACK TO THE SOUTH
AND EAST OF THE COUNTRY,
REMAINED ON THE WRONG SIDE OF A
LINE THAT HAS HARDENED.
>> Translator: RUSSIA IS USING
HYBRID METHODS OF OCCUPATION.
THAT MEANS THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION IS TRYING TO IDENTIFY
AND DESTROY SENSITIVE
RESISTANCE.
UKRAINIAN PARTISANS SOME PEOPLE
OFTEN DISAPPEAR IN RUSSIAN
PRISONS.
>> Reporter: WHICH IS WHY THE
YELLOW RIBBON MOVEMENT BECAME
KEY ACCORDING TO A SPOKESPERSON
IN KYIV.
HE TELLS ME THE RIBBONS ARE FOR
PEOPLE TO PASS ON THE MESSAGE
THAT UKRAINE IS PRESENT HERE,
THAT THERE IS NO OTHER SOUTH
THAN UNDER THE UKRAINIAN FLAG.
HERE IN ZAPORIZHZHIA, THERE'S
ALSO A SENSE THAT THAT LINE
BETWEEN RUSSIAN-CONTROLLED
UKRAINE AND THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY IS HARDENING EVEN AS IT
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD.
WE CAN HEAR HERE THE REGULAR
SOUND OF OUTGOING ARTILLERY FIRE
BUT ALSO SEE AN EMERGING REFUGEE
CRISIS.
HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES LIVING IN
THEIR CARS AS THEY TRY TO GET
BACK TO THEIR HOMES, NOW, IN
RUSSIAN-CONTROLLED CITIES.
THOSE PEOPLE, HOPING TO GET BACK
TO THEIR CITIES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THAT LINE TONIGHT,
POPPY, NO LONGER ABLE TO SPEAK
TO RELATIVES, THERE'S BEEN
COMMUNICATIONS BLOCKOUT WITH
INTERNET AND TELEPHONE DOWN AS
WELL MAKING THAT STORY HARDER TO
TELL.
THE FREE PRESS SIMPLY HASN'T HAD
ACCESS TO.
THOSE IMAGES YOU SAW AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PORT, THE CAR
BOMB IN MARIUPOL, BROADCAST BY
RUSSIAN TV.
OTHERWISE, IT IS FROM PEOPLE
LIKE THAT MAN, THE MAYOR OF
MARIUPOL NOW IN EXILE HE